la journée s'annonçait spectaculaire dès
les toutes premières heures un soleil de
plomb et très peu de vent la capsule
soyouz est apparue au dessus de nos
têtes
telle une montgolfière qui se baladent
paisiblement dans ciel il ne restait
plus que 10 km soit 15 minutes à peine à
voir qu'elle se pose
seul c'était la course contre la montre
une valse d'hélicoptères et de camions
tout le monde était prêt les secouristes
n'ont mis que quelques minutes pour
déverrouiller la porte de la capsule
pour en sortir d'abord le commandant
russe oleg konan n co puis l'américaine
anne madeleine qui était de tout sourire
[Applaudissements]
david saint jacques est sorti le dernier
visiblement affaibli les forces de la
gravité s'impose mais les malaises et
les nausées sont fréquents visiblement
pénible quand ça fait des mois qu'on phl
dans l'espace entourés de leurs médecins
les trois astronautes ont rattrapé leur
souffle et même appelé à la maison avant
d'être transporté dans cette tente
médicale érigé au milieu des steppes
kazakhes
les russes cents aux traditions et
parades et les combinaisons spatiales de
leurs héros en est une qui est sacré un
hommage à leur courage et à leur exploit
quand david saint-jacques est sorti de
la tente une fois examinés il avait
enfin les deux pieds sur terre escorté
par ses médecins ça sent l'essence était
première tombe du ciel tellement tombe
du ciel une fois une fois qu on se
convainc que c'est pas dangereux
le bain d'abord nous sommes chanceux
d'être venu mais c'est un peu nous ait
eu
puis mais je suis sûr ce qui me surprend
c'est l'odeur cette odeur c'était plus
précisément l'odeur de la camomille
sauvage
rapidement ils redécouvrent les petites
douceurs de la terre mais il devra
l'apprivoiser à nouveau réapprendre à
marcher à bouger normalement il faudra
des semaines il est difficile de croire
qu'après tout ce périple il s'est envolé
à nouveau direction la nasa aux états
unis il ya de bonnes chances avec la
technologie qui avance rapidement et les
tests qui sont concluants que le
prochain astronaute canadien s'envole et
atterrissent à bord d'une des nouvelles
générations diffusé pour l'instant la
seule use est encore le seul taxi qui
fait l'aller-retour vers l'espace et on
a pu voir aujourd'hui un atterrissage
spectaculaire merris il cite avoir
altéré sco radio canada au kazakhstan